how she gon brooch my name is fearful
we're paying customer Korea that I
nailed that pronunciation I think yes a
long long time ago
what's the next dialogue that's it okay
long long time ago I was a naked man
whose face you bros remember and this
[ __ ] UFO kept shooting me at [ __ ]
what an [ __ ]
am i right what do I do now it says
press s okay I will place a blank we
discovered smarmy nice one all Phil
Gramm on by a bleep ass keep blending
shed for the swim nice this is so
exciting he's shooting me
Democrat
god damn immigrant let's keep growing
our soil there we go
great that's just great whoa holy [ __ ]
no one told me I had a jet pack get back
my naked child your orange fruit plant
is collected
let's keep planting [ __ ] and killing
immigrants this game sends a great
message to the people of yet you know
we're just gonna go off in space now
[ __ ] this alright ground control to
Major Tom I'm just gonna go off to space
with my best friend jar of acid
all right I'm lining on this play God
yeah baby red let's place a flag here
this is my home now
this is Petra let me just pick my jar of
acid and go back into hyperspace no I'm
too fat apparently no no we're good I
think there's there's a planet over here
right let's not get lost in it damn it
right
I very low on jet pack fuel I'm probably
gonna probably gonna die here
I'm naked in spirit
Hey
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god I
almost died all right well let's land on
this [ __ ] ow sorry guys this is
my planet now you can all just suck a
big fat [ __ ] tentacle dick other
life-forms just need to learn and
appreciate my presence all right it's be
Drake shield face that's pretty good
okay so now we have a shield base let's
build some more flowers shall we shan't
we
that [ __ ] ate my shield base
spend all your time waiting
for that second chain can you feel the
love
mmm I can feel it it's there rotting my
plans I put my love inside all my plants
just face yeah my nakedness will inspire
the universe a boss you know it looks
you know I got apply it I got a plan
it's conquer the planet bundage er then
let's use a supernova that's right boss
you died bus this music hello hello
hello
if you reveal the [ __ ] for you for
your tower this is getting intense man
this is getting out of [ __ ] cold man
I can't build anything else that's like
I have a future as you and me yo pee on
shower that's the boss ah what down what
are you gonna for my jollies say take
this bottom center
go naked man yo let's time goodbye
no no no no no no no no no no [ __ ]
this game is hard man I got two planets
are you kidding me are you I'm so
embarrassed I have an award for best
gamer I think I deserve better
this game is glitched I'm shaking it
looks like we're gonna have to end it
there anyway it's an interesting game
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed please leave a like hit
subscribe to come bro today it supports
me and what I do why would you I don't
know but as always it's funny cuz huge
let's pretend that we're a school mom
and we need to drive our kids to school
and be really [ __ ] short on time my
god we made that jump like a [ __ ]
boss Wow